-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
I'm doing well.
[ Laughter ]
Let's get to the news.
According
to The Washington Post,
President Biden exercises
most mornings
by lifting weights
before he begins work.
That makes sense
because he is clearly
not using the StairMaster.
[ Laughter ]
I'm sorry, but the clip is fun
He's fine.
[ Laughter ]
According to
The Washington Post,
President Biden occasionally
goes to the South Lawn
or Rose Garden during the da
to get fresh air
with his dogs, Champ and Major
while the rest of the staf
goes literally anywhere else
Somebody commented me
that it's time
to stop making fun
of Major biting people.
I feel like a year.
He has to go a year
without biting anyone.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden said on Friday
that he would not allow
the Justice Department
to seize the phone records
of journalists.
Well, that explains
Matt Gaetz's new hat.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden has reportedly
continued a tradition,
started
by former President Obama,
of reading ten letters
each night
that are sent to the White House
by individual Americans.
Though, in the Obama days,
they were mostly from Joe.
[ Laughter ]
Former Vice President Mike Pence
and former
Second Lady Karen Pence
have reportedly purchased a ne
home outside of Indianapolis
And, of course,
it was outside the city
because you know this guy
doesn't go downtown.
[ Laughter ]
Baze!
Alex Baze,
as I live and breathe!
[ Laughter ]
A New York librarian
was arrested last Friday
for allegedly robbing a bank
Well, trying to, at least.
[ Whispering ]
Okay, everyone hit the floor
[ Laughter ]
Because they'd whisper
outside the library.
[ Laughter ]
That's the thing
about librarians.
People think it's
about the library.
It's fundamentally inside them
It was announced last week
that Pope Francis
will get a new
electric Popemobile.
Of course, before he can plu
the charger into the outlet,
they have to get married.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new study,
dogs can effectively detec
the coronavirus
with 97% accuracy,
which is great news becaus
that's the only provider
in your network.
Scientists reported that the
largest iceberg in the world
broke off from Antarctica
last week
and it's roughly 70 times
larger than Manhattan.
Yeah, but I bet they don't hav
any good restaurants.
And, finally, yesterday wa
Lucky Penny Day.
Right, because who's luckier
than Abraham Lincoln?
[ Laughter ]
Look, I don't have to read
the Mike Scollins jokes.
I get that.
[ Laughter ]
But, if I didn't,
you wouldn't know
what I'm putting up with,
day in and day out.
[ Laughter ]
"If you see something,
say something."
[ Laughter ]
That was a monologue, everybody.